hello readers today i want to talk about
themes
a theme is an important idea that is
woven throughout a story it's not the
plot or the summary but something a
little deeper
a theme links a big idea about our world
with the action of a text
sometimes a theme answers a question the
story is trying to explore like what
does it mean to be a family or what are
we afraid of
themes will be statements that answer
these questions like you don't have to
be related to someone for them to be
your family or we are afraid of losing
our individuality now theme is different
from the main idea of a story or its
summary the main idea is what the story
is all about and the summary is the
events of the story it's the plot it's
what happened but the theme is a lesson
or a message that you can take out of
the story and apply to your own life
themes are universal that is to say
anyone can relate to them
so if i tell you a story about how i got
food poisoning the one time i ate a
sketchy roadside hot dog instead of
packing my own lunch the theme isn't
avoid sticky pete's hot dogs on route 91
the theme is it pays to be prepared
because not everyone has a sticky piece
but everyone can be prepared
ugh why did i eat it why is it green
a theme is similar to a moral but a
moral is more about a specific lesson
it's trying to teach you a theme could
be a lesson but it doesn't have to be
sometimes you can discover the theme by
asking yourself some big questions
what did the characters learn
how did they grow and change
why did characters act the way they
acted what's different at the end of the
story
and what stays with you after the story
is over let's go through a folk tale and
see if answering these questions helps
us to uncover the theme
this is a story about a nancy the spider
a heroic trickster from west africa
anansi was clever but he wished to be
wise wiser than everyone in fact he
decided that he'd take all the wisdom he
could find all the wisdom in the whole
world and gather it all inside a little
clay pot
but he didn't like having it in the
house this pot of knowledge
what if our kid knocks it over he asked
his wife also what if someone comes over
in the night and steals it who's coming
to steal your pot a nancy she asked
nobody even knows you have it it's not
safe a nancy cried and he decided to
hide it i'm going out he said don't
follow me whatever said osso who went
back to doing something that was
actually useful
anansi wandered through the forest
lugging this enormous clay pot of wisdom
never aware that his little son ntikuma
was following close behind
not tall enough said anansi looking at a
cliff
not deep enough he said frowning at a
canyon
aha said a nancy when he came to the
prickly thorne tree at the edge of the
forest near a little stream now this
will do just fine
anansi had many legs and he was very
strong but even he could not climb the
tree and carry the pot of knowledge at
the same time he scrabbled up the tree
then slid back down again
he wiggled up the tree then slid back
down again he clambered up the tree hey
dad a nancy's son called out what what i
said nobody follow me what are you doing
here anansi cried you should tie the pot
to your back dad then you can use all
your legs to climb the tree
he was right but it didn't matter to a
nancy i'll teach you to give me advice
you little miscreant announcer yelled
shaking his fist
the same fist that held the handle to
the pot full of wisdom
it went sailing into the air as time
seemed to slow down oh no said anansi oh
no said a nancy's little son and the pot
smashed open right there in the stream
carrying all of a nancy's carefully
gathered up knowledge into the ocean
sending it out to the whole world once
again
you are in so much trouble in tikuma
anansi said clambering back down the
tree and then he said ow ow ow because
in his haste he had poked himself on the
thorns of the tree
his son took off running for home and
anansi raced after him and as they ran
it began to rain
and as the rain came down anansi stopped
running and began to walk
and think ntikuma's plan would have
worked after all
when he at last caught up with intikuma
he apologized for losing his temper
what was the use of all that wisdom if i
can still be outsmarted by my little son
he said
the two of them embraced
and because of intikum's timely
interruption a little bit of a nancy's
knowledge lives in us all today
so our questions checklist
what did the characters learn well
anansi learned that even if he had all
the wisdom in the world a child could
still have a better idea than him
how did the characters grow and change
anansi apologized for losing his temper
and realized that he wasn't the only
person with good ideas
why did characters act the way they
acted i think anansi was greedy why else
would he want to have all the wisdom in
the world and not share it with anybody
else
and what's different at the end of the
story
at the end of the story everybody gets a
little bit from the pot of wisdom it
flows out into the ocean and gets sent
to everybody and anansi realized that
keeping all the wisdom to himself still
didn't make him the wisest all the time
finally what stays with you after the
story is over
the fact that all of us you me your aunt
matilda all of us have a little bit of a
nazi's wisdom inside of us so a theme of
this story could be anyone can have a
good idea or wisdom is inside all of us
what theme would you give this story
discuss it with your friends your
classmates your family and let us know
the theme of all of my videos is and
shall forever be that you can learn
anything
dave it out